そうよああいいし
まじかまじか
低評価が非表示熱舞うか本日は弾み雪は
です低評価が批評ずになるのかちょっと
あのヒカキンさんも動画出されてたんです
けども私はじめ者とかつですねあのゴルフ
クラブをへし折る動画を出して低評価に
12万だったら懐かしいなんて評価を8
22万低評価叩きだしたあの低評価を
なかなか低評価たわけで20万超える人
ってそうそう日本にいないと思うんで
かつてねあの最近始めたつを見たよって
いう人とか若い子は知らないと思うけど昔
始めそうちょっとやんちゃだったんよああ
今もんだけどなおだけども昔はすごい
やんちゃで炎上したことも多々あったりし
てね6 lover へっ背負ってしまっ
た動画があってそれの低評価が22万
22000422万低評価を築いた男とし
てこれはちょっと話さなきゃいけないなと
思ってちょっと方はせていただきます
ちょっとなんで消えたのかちょっと調べて
みましょうかあります youtube
定評官の数を非公開に嫌がらせ帽子
なるほどねーなんで定評陥落する理由から
すると動画クリエイターを嫌がらせや個人
攻撃から守るため動画の低評価数を非表示
飛行がにすると発表したらしいです
youtube のユーザーも皆さんは
今後低評価ボタンをクリックできますが
押せるは押せますどんだけ定評が来てるか
皆さんは見れなくなってしまうらしいです
でクリエイター側は自分の投稿者ドアの低
評価数が確認できると千葉さん曰くへと
視聴者さんとクリエイター官の兄ある交流
の促進のため低評価ボタンを非公開にする
実験を実施したら嫌がらせや低評価講義が
減少したと説明しているらしいですおお
なるほどねーなくなっちまうな家庭評価
まあその嫌がらせとかで定評が大須賀た花
もちもいらっしゃいますし炎上している人
にはもってつくんですけども個人的な感想
時一言言わせていただくと
ちょっとつまんないなと
思いますねー
はいしません個人的な感想ですよこれが
良い悪い別にして個人的にはうわーなんか
つまんなくなっちゃうなというのが
思いましたねぇもう誰も当時の俺みたいに
メンターのズタズタになることはないのか
なちょっとできますみなさん22万人の人
にこう指中指たから中指ではないは22万
人の人にこうされる気持ちを
[音楽]
まあ
つらかったですね22万人にこれされたの
は結構つながったやっぱり低評価っていう
のはねそれが悪いって言われることだから
その数が多ければ多いこと言ったり
つらかったしもちろんメンターヤバかっ
たってもずたつだというかもちろん僕が
悪いなぁまつげないんですけどそれでも
やっぱ大勢の知らない人他人じゃないです
か顔もわからないし知らない人からこう
やってね不快感や敵意をむき出しにされる
のってすごいやっぱりつらかったしますの
で経験者だから言うんですけど本当に辛い
ものではあったんですけどメンター僕は
それを乗り越える努力は楽しかったなと
思ってるタイプの人間です良いものに入っ
てつくのって当たり前じゃないですか他の
sns とが見てもさあなら
youtube 竹内の低評価っていう
あるそれがなんかすごいなと思ってたん
ですけどまさか無くなっちゃうと
無くなっちゃうと何が起きるかというと
パッと見た瞬間でいいものしか目に入ら
ないんで何だろうねなんか低評価がどれ
だけ付いてるかって結構
クリエイターもそうですし見てる皆様気に
してたら何か面白さ youtube の
面白さの1つだったのかなと思って
ちょっとつまらなくなるなあって
思いましたもちろんその面白さのせいです
が傷ついた人僕がはですよ妄想一人だから
ね何だろう第一にしたよそこらへんの炎上
した人と一緒にしないでほしいね僕は提供
間に12まぁそんな地獄のような体験を得
た僕が言うといえば説得力あるんで言わせ
ていただきますけども面白いですよ
低評価っていうシステム good だけ
あるものより絶対にこっちついたほうが人
って見たくなるんですよねその中嫌がらせ
とか辛いとかなんか精神的苦痛とかを
取り除くとまず実に面白く無くなっちゃう
なぁちょっとつまんなくなっちゃうバーン
つまんなくなっちゃうなとかつての炎上は
そう言っておりますまあけどほんとがあの
youtube さんのおっしゃる通りで
嫌がらせ攻撃まあ本当になくならないなと
思います御今も誰かせる絶対塩蔵してるし
その動画とは関係ない低評価とか絶対ある
と思うんですよ動画がすごい面白くて
よかったとしても過去に炎上してたせいで
t 評価がたくさん付くとかまぁそれも
その人は悪いんですけどそういう部分を
含めて面白さなのかなとか思うんですけど
優しい世界になりそう
かなそういう面白さはなくなりますけれど
も今よりかばまあいい youtube
ちょっと優しい youtube になる
のかなとは思いますが逆に役に僕が不安な
のが悪い
なんかしてやろうこれよくないって思った
時に低評価ポチって押すだけでよかったの
が
すみませんねよくわかりません俺もわかっ
てないんで今の状況が今までさんなんか
めんどくさい人とかこれはダメだな悪い
なって思ったらで評価ポチって押すだけで
済んでた人がほかの市長さんに共感を得
られなかったり他の見ている人へのず分の
その意思の伝え方がでリーダーになっ
ちゃうわけなのでワンちゃんコメント欄
もっと荒れるんじゃないかなとも思います
はかないですけどだって悪いって見せ方
ないんでしょて評価が見えなかったらさ
どうやってみせるかっていうともう
コメントで書くしかないと思うんですよ何
が悪いかどうして悪いのか何か今までさ
このボタン一つを見て進んでたことがよ
クレーターが今後さらにそういうはっきり
した悪意のある文章と会や会社の文とかを
目にする機会が増えちゃうのかなと思いま
わかんないですけどね僕あの2万なら言い
ますけど低評価に12万食らってから結構
コメントラベルのトラウマになっちゃって
ちょっと嫌だなって思ったコメントを見
ないようにしてるんですよ
傷つきたくないから長いひどい批判とか
誹謗2社のコメントを見てよりも俺はこれ
だけ見てた方がまだ
いいと思ってるタイプだからでこれが
なくなるわけじゃん非表示なるわけだ
そしたらそういうさあもしこれの理由がよ
嫌がらせとか誹謗中傷とか本当に悪意の
あるコメントだったらこれで住んでいた
ことがちゃんと文章化されてくるってわけ
だからなんかねえ
うんっちょっと俺は強いなとも思います
拝島線なんか初めてダンスよコメント
ラベルの強いとかいうことを言いコメント
はもちろん見てますしなんか
youtube に感謝嫌なことから目を
そむけはいいと思ってたようなんで嫌な
コメントは見ないようにします嫌な
コメントはほんとねなんかちょっといい
怪しいなと思ったらもう目に育てちゃうん
でそうやって私肇社長はメンタルを保って
今やってきておりますたと言ってさあその
自分の youtube でだした動画が
良いか悪いか気になるからその指標として
ぐっとそしてバットもすごいちゃんと見て
たから good もたくさんもちろん
欲しいけどバットを減らしたいっていう
努力も釣ってきたんですけどねちょっと
どうなっちゃうんだろうねで言うのは
ちょっと思いましたね
もう見れなくなってるんかななんかもう
すぐ見れなくなると言ってるんですねぇー
だからパッドなんか知り合いの配信見たら
高評価0 chan ど亭様が乗っ取られ
ないかちゃんと低評価4付いとるわ高評価
0でいつから実装されるんだろうでもう
なんかされてるっぽいよねけどもう間も
なくな気がしますね低評価消えるの
嫌がらせとか誹謗中傷なくなるに越した
ことはないと思いますけどその動画に出し
たコメントができる以上はヘリはするけど
も多分頭をしたら消えないことだと思うし
まあて栄養価が高くなってね少しでも平和
な世界にはなると思うんですけどもう者
youtube の特徴と言いますか
youtube ならではの機能の1つが
消えちゃったなとは思います0票が抗議と
かする人のせいだよこうなったのは原因が
嫌がらせにあるんだったらほんとそれしか
ないの炎上中はねどんな動画だしても低
評価突きまくる経験も僕はありますしまし
たそれで22万食らってるんで正直結構
説得力あるほど人間だと思うんですよ嫌
がらせを受けた身からするとあのどう
しようもない感じ精神的に辛い感じすごい
わかるしこの気持ちをこんな苦しい思いを
する人が減るのであればまあん
アリかなと思いますなんか選択制にすれば
いいなって思いますね基本的に高評価も低
評価もつくんですけどもなんかも選択で
って8日を非表示にできるっていうのが
選択制にしたらいいかなと思いますけどね
やを論じ上そういうこっちじゃなくて
こっちどれぐらいあるかどうかってみる
のってちょっとあの僕はもう言うずいぶ
大好きなんでもう youtube さん
の意向に従うだけなんですけども
クリエイターさんを守る面では良いと思い
ますただ youtube 的なその面白
さ的な部分はちょっと減っちゃうのかな
っていう寂しい気持ちはあるかなという
結論ですいやでもなわからんだそう分
コメント欄が大変なことになりそうな気も
するけどでもまあなんか実験でてるって
分かってるんだそうだったらいいんじゃ
ないでしょうか
[音楽]
懐かしいな低評価に常にまんでしょその後
ちゃんと陥ってしまったゴルフクラブの
会社にアノ謝罪させていただいたりもした
んで人って
過ちを犯しちゃう生き物だと思うんで大字
南そこからどうするかだと思うんですよね
なんかその失敗しちゃった人が頑張って
いくストーリーのスパイスとして低評価
減ってるなーとか買わないなとか見ていっ
た人もいると思うから本当に何か面白さの
1つだったらとは思いますないけど本当に
人が来ずつかないに越したことはないんで
いいと思います
[音楽]